collecte à monsieur daniel fasquelle
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre s'adresse à manuel
valls premier ministre et vont lui poser
ma question je vais lui dire que pour
faire l'unité nationale encore faut-il
faudrait-il est d'abord capable de faire
l'unité de sa majorité à quelques jours
de la journée mondiale de l'autisme du 2
avril
la france m'a malheureusement encore se
faire remarquer en raison de son
incapacité à rattraper 40 ans de retard
en matière de prise en charge de ce
handicap qui frappe dans notre pays
six cent mille personnes certes depuis
12 années où l'autisme a été déclarée
grande cause nationale
certains progrès ont été réalisés grâce
notamment au troisième plan autisme mais
les chiffres sont là et ils sont
accablants en 2014 selon une étude
publiée par le collectif autisme
quarante quatre personnes des personnes
aux tic 44% des personnes autistes était
victime soit de mauvais traitements
soient de carence en matière de soins la
maltraitance reste donc la norme comme
vient de le rappeler le comité des
droits de l'enfant de l'onu
dans ses observations finales publiées
le 4 février dernier
il est donc plus que temps de réagir
d'entendre le cri de détresse des
familles et de répondre à leurs attentes
monsieur le premier ministre quand allez
vous rendre enfin opposable en france
des recommandations de bonne pratique de
la haute autorité de santé et donc
imposer les méthodes éducatives et
comportementales les seuls efficace et
reconnu partout dans le monde
quand allez vous enfin financer sur
fonds publics des éducateurs formés pour
permettre aux 80 mille enfants atteints
de troubles autistiques d'aller à
l'école ou à défaut de recevoir une
éducation adaptée
quand allez vous enfin fermer les
établissements maltraitant et interdire
les formations non conforme qui sont
encore aujourd'hui imposé dans nombre
d'établissements en france
quand allez vous enfin interdire le
packing une pratique moyenâgeuse
notre pays doit devrait avoir honte en
conclusion monsieur prémunissent quand
la france pourra-t-elle être fier de
s'associer enfin à la journée mondiale
de l'autisme
la parole est à madame ségolène neuville
secrétaire d'état chargé des personnes
handicapées la lutte contre l'exclusion
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
député fasquelle
je sais que tout comme votre collègue
gwendal rouillard vous connaissez bien
le sujet de l'autisme puisque vous co
présidé avec lui le groupe d'études
parlementaire sur le sujet et puisque
vous connaissez bien ce sujet et
d'ailleurs vous l'avez dit vous savez ce
que disent les associations en france
l'année zéro de l'autisme c'est 2012
parce que c'est l'année de parution de
diffusion des recommandations de la
haute autorité de santé et de l'anesm
et puisque vous connaissez bien le sujet
vous savez aussi que c'est ce
gouvernement qui a engagé 205 millions
d'euros dans le troisième plan autisme
troisième fois autisme qui met en oeuvre
scrupuleusement les recommandations de
la haute autorité de santé
malgré les polémiques malgré les remises
en cause y compris dans la presse il ya
encore quelques jours dans un grand
quotidien national
c'est ce gouvernement qui a décidé que
la scolarisation des enfants avec
autisme était une priorité avec
notamment la création de 110 unités
d'enseignement maternel c'est ce
gouvernement qui a décidé que la
formation massive de l'ensemble des
professionnels de l'autisme était une
priorité avec des milliers et des
milliers de professionnels qui sont
formés chaque année aux recommandations
de la haute autorité de santé
c'est ce gouvernement qui a décidé
d'organiser des inspections dans les
hôpitaux de jour de pédopsychiatrie pour
vérifier la mise en oeuvre justement des
recommandations de la haute autorité de
santé dans ces hôpitaux de jour est bien
entendu bien entendu le packing et
concernés par ces inspections parce que
le packing est une méthode qui n'est
absolument pas recommandée et sur le cac
king je veux être très clair monsieur le
député parce que la position de ce
gouvernement c'est exactement la
position de la haute autorité de santé
c'est exactement la position de l'onu et
des mesures seront prises prochainement
pour justement aller plus loin sur ce
sujet comme vous le voyez monsieur le
député le gouvernement et merci la
parole est à monsieur richard et grands